this is an all electric version of Audis
r8 sports car it's called the r8 e-tron
edition it's fully electric it's
extremely fast it does 0 to 60 in under
5 seconds it's also very lightweight the
body is aluminum with carbon fiber
details throughout it's already been
tested in real-world race situations
they just put it on the track at 24
hours of them on it has 1200 pounds of
batteries inside of it and it takes
about two and a half hours to fully
charge and on that charge you can go
around 150 miles so it has quite an
impressive range for an electric car it
has four individual electric motors one
on top of each wheel so it's an
extension of Audis Quattro all-wheel
drive system that it's had in its cars
since forever it's not for sale yet but
Audi is going to make a few hundred of
them available to select buyers next
year in 2012